So Layer Blocks sounds like
a powerful technology.
Can you reflect any on
what change it's meant to
people as they're confronted with
developing a new application?
Do they think about the architecting
of it now any differently
than they did in the past?
>> Certainly, when we build new
instances of the forecaster.
It changes dramatically how we
think about configuring that,
because now there's a lot more structure
in place based on the existence of
Layer Blocks itself and these assembly
specifications to allow us to plan for
a new configuration of this capability.
And to divvy up the parts
when executing it.
In terms of new capabilities,
I think it's been a mixed bag in
the sense of I think that people
often find it very difficult
to come up with the right abstractions,
initially.
So, even with Layer Blocks and
with this approach kind of in the bag of
tools, we often don't immediately think,
when we have a new problem to solve,
that it's going to be a product line.
Or that's this is
the right way to solve it.
And I don't know what to do about that.
Perhaps if we got better at,
kind of, a priori feature analysis,
it would be more obvious.
Or perhaps maybe,
you have to build one or two products
in a product line to recognize that you
have a product line there to begin with.
I'm not really sure, I think it's
still kind of an open question.
But that's been our experience to date.
>> The other thing I'd
like to ask you is, for
the benefit of the students who might
want to become software architects.
Do you have any reflection on
the relationship between, kind of,
the academic knowledge that you
learn about software design,
software architecture and
what you have to confront in the real
world with doing software architecture?
>> So,
let me think of a few things that.
It's all over the map.
I've found that, in the last seven
years, I've used just about every
thing that I've learned in
a software engineering course that,
at the time, seemed very abstract and
perhaps I thought I'd never use this.
I do.
But let me try to be concrete about
things I've found that are definitely
useful skills.
So, maybe the biggest one for
me is, well two.
One is data modeling,
be it data modelling using ER,
or ORM, or UML, or whatever.
Getting really good at
modeling at a conceptual level
the structure of data in a system.
If you're going to build any kind
of system like the ones I'm just
mentioning, that is
a really critical skill.
And even though it's taught pretty
well in database courses and
a lot of people take database courses,
you'd be amazed at just how rare
it is to be really good at that.
So, getting facility and
data modeling and
not applying it just to database design,
but to any kind of information design
problem at all, I've found it extremely
useful and to really pay dividends.
I've also found it really useful to
get really comfortable with many
different models of
software composition,
because you just never know when one
might be useful and they often are.
So, when I was a student
at Georgia Tech,
I spent a lot of time
learning how to use
process algebras and CSP, FSP, LOTOS.
There's a whole family of
these action languages
that were very interesting to me.
And we covered them in classes,
and we learned how to use them.
And they have very nice compositional
capabilities that were very elegant and
very clean and were very well-studied.
But it wasn't really clear
how to use them in something.
There was not a compiler that you would
write programs in this language to use
to build a big piece of your system.
But over time,
I've found that they come back a lot.
In fact, we've started using them
in LogicBlox as the basis for
building a batch automation framework
where you've got this problem
of designing work flows.
And you have to compose them, and
you need to compose them using
a small number of very
clearly defined operators.
And doing it cleanly and
being able to reason about it.
So, things like that
have been very useful.
Petri nets, which I studied many, many
years ago, and also seemed like a nice,
elegant way to think about concurrency,
and data flows, and work flows.
Again, it's not immediately obvious
how to just take that and use it, but
you'll find that they'll inspire
designs that you'll see in the future.
And they'll be just the right thing when
you run into some architectural problem.
What are some others?
Any kind of algebraic approach to
thinking about software composition,
I think that, maybe,
is the underlying theme.
If you can understand nice, clean,
elegant models of software composition.
What are their properties?
When are they useful?
How can you use them to
inspire the designs?
You'll find that a lot of infrastructure
work that you do tends to be better by
having been inspired by these ideas that
have been worked out by a lot of very
smart people over many years, rather
than try to come up with it yourself.
And, I guess, maybe the last thing
I'd say is a segue from that, and
that is this is not something that
we tend to to very well generally
as software developers.
But knowing a body of related work,
and when you start a new problem,
try to relate your problem to
a problem that has already been seen,
because chances are someone
has solved it or
solved some variant of it that
you can heavily borrow from.
I think that's huge, and I think that
that's maybe the biggest piece of
advice I would give to
a budding software architect.
>> So what I'm hearing is the world
is filled with all kinds of complex
problems and the more weapons you
can bring to bear to solving them,
the more likely you are to be able
get a handle on that complexity.
>> Indeed, Indeed.
>> Well, Kurt, this has been a wonderful
story you have to tell about this,
and I'm glad that you were able
to apply some of your academic
background to solving it.
And I just want to thank you very much
for conveying that story to the class.
>> You're very welcome, and thank you
for the opportunity to tell the story.